Today we'll talk about Analogical Reasoning.
Analogical Reasoning involves understanding new problems,
in terms of family of problems. It also involves addressing new problems, but
transferring knowledge of relationships from known problems across domains.
We introduced a notion of transfer previously in explanation based learning.
We also have talked about Case Based Reasoning.
Today we'll talk about transfer in a much more general manner.
We'll start by talking about similarity then revisit case based reasoning.
Then we'll talk through the overall process of analogical reasoning,
including retrieval, and mapping, and transport. Then we'll close by
talking about a specific application of analogy, called Design by Analogy.